all right one more quick topic for you
ends day before we take our first break
because this one has come up by virtue
of the fact that the Cowboys are six and
seven the Eagles are six and seven one
of those two teams is going to win the
NFC East and host a playoff game
most likely against a Seahawks or 49ers
team that will be twelve and four or
thirteen and three so the concept of
reseeding
to take away that automatic home game
for a division champion whose record is
inferior to a wild-card teams record the
Commissioner was asked on there's any on
whether there's any thought being given
to changing the way that playoff teams
are seated here's what he said this is
not the first time this conversations
occurred where the situation's occurred
as you know teams go into the season the
first objective is to win the division
that's what they work on is we win the
division we get in the playoffs and that
is something that we've considered over
the years I have not heard that this
year don't anticipate hearing it again
again it's been discussed in the past
but I don't see that as an issue now if
it comes up we'll certainly have the
conversation I don't know dissipate it
kind of muddy the issue there a little
bit if you win the division you do get
into the playoffs the question is do you
deserve to host a playoff game right
when you're facing a team that has a
record better than yours there's an
inequity there that he the weather
deliberately or inadvertently danced
around it because at some point you have
to stand up and say yeah we have no
problem with the team that could in
theory be as bad as four and twelve
hosting a team that could be thirteen
and three or fourteen and two yeah we've
got no issue with that well if that
would ever happen they instantly would
have an issue with it and it would
change it and that's kind of the way the
NFL does things there's a potential
problem hiding in plain sight and they
see it happen from time to time at a
lower level but when it blows up and it
embarrasses the NFL that's when they
have to change it immediately right and
we haven't had that moment yet we've
been close we've had some teams that
have flirted with it right I'm in favor
of the way they're doing it right now I
am why well why because first off there
should be something that you get from
winning your division
second of you to go to the playoffs okay
well okay second but you get to go to
the playoffs but you should still to get
to host a home playoff
for winning your division my second
point would be this you know like
strength of schedule and who you play
matters like if you go back to 2014 with
that Carolina Panthers team that was
seven eight and one you look at their
schedule compared to the Arizona
Cardinals who had a way better record
that year but got thumped by Carolina in
that wild-card game because the Carolina
Panthers have had to play the AFC North
which had three playoff teams their
schedule that self they had to play
three of the NFC playoff teams and then
they also had to play the great Drew
Brees and the great Matt Ryan and the
explosive offense there are four times
along with that so their schedule was
way greater and more competitive than
the Arizona Cardinals who had a better
record yes but then they went into
Carolina and I know Carson Palmer wasn't
planned but they got thumped in that
game like thoroughly dominated and then
the next week Carolina went to Seattle
who was the great Seattle Seahawks off
the Superbowl championship and played a
very competitive close game Cam Newton's
down there ready to make it a one score
game with six minutes left in the game
and kam chancellor returns a 91 yard
touchdown pass so that would be
instances like that would be why I would
argue against it and I think there's a
more fundamental reason for owners and
it has to do with the money that comes
from hosting a playoff that's even
though the league controls the process
you do make a lot of extra money as an
owner by hosting a playoff game and
under the current structure the way it
works I mean in theory in every given
year you've got a one in four chance of
hosting a playoff game yeah except in
the AFC East I mean but even then going
into the year yeah there's one of us
will host a playoff game that's right
enjoy the financial windfall that comes
from it so they don't want to change
that there's also a fear that once you
start down that path of not respecting
the division champion not giving the
division champion a home game maybe they
do end up reseeding the playoffs
entirely based upon finish in the
conference and you could have a team
that that loses an automatic playoff
berth that at some point they're gonna
say yeah we know we separate this into
divisions but we're gonna take the six
best teams regardless of what division
you're in and if you're not one of them
I mean look there's gonna be an 11 and 5
team potentially this year yeah that is
screwed out of a playoff spot in phase
of a team that may go seven and nine I
know and you know you can see you have
regardless of schedules and I don't
think that we can we can play the
schedule card this year the reality is
the four teams in the NFC East Inc this
year that's right one of them is gonna
play ryan game in the play no you're
right you're a hundred percent that's
exactly and it's tough but it doesn't
happen a lot and you're right I mean
Dallas and the Eagles stink and it's
hard to argue it this year
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports